pub
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bravo les belles démonstrations je
voulais m'amuser pour une dernière fois
c'est fini le temps du siècle maintenant
il faut travailler
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
hamon
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
vive l'armée sergent naber ville
tu as trouvé quelque chose oh c'est pas
les propositions qui manquent
mécanicien dans une usine de cycles
chauffeur livreur chez samsung on m'a
même proposé un poste de balayeurs et
toi je vive entier mon père on parle
d'avion
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
d'après lui 14 c'est peut-être rimbaud
il a rempilé et la post tracteur pour la
pilote de chasse au moins il vole lui
alors facteurs ont fait sa tournée
qu'est ce que vous faites là comité
d'accueil mon lit et non pas pour
longtemps
j'arrive à fin de contrat repos
effectuée en vue alors bienvenue au club
quel club le club des chômeurs alors osé
ça
[Musique]
et jeudi
je suis content et après qu'est ce que
tu fais pas de mal à ça toute l'aviation
113 ici toute fraîche
est ce que tu es devenu blasé du cirque
elle est chouette l'aviation française
un facteur un clone de chômeurs à noël
donc si on allait boire un verre ou deux
par jeu pour sa sinistrement ici ben on
peut aller chez moi mon père vient de
louer un appartement
on est en plein camping paraît qu'il a
invité les gens ra joséphine la femme
détiennent
[Musique]
qu'est ce qu'il devient mais pas reparti
pour le canada non elle a trouvé un
boulot dans le cinéma comme journaliste
aux actualités avec jolie un ami de mon
père ce sera sinistre on boira du
champagne chaud par avion beau programme
[Musique]
ah j'ai peut-être mieux à vous proposer
- cocktail champagne petits fours hôtel
particulier du beau monde qui qui
regrette que la guerre sera finie parce
que la guerre ça a été leur fortune je
suis invité par le fils un jeune connu
pire est que l'avion alors
il y aura des filles superbes la musique
[ __ ] bon une phase passe les petits
fours la java pile papa les souvenirs de
joséphine
[Musique]
je sais
8on admirateurs ouais elle a passé son
père sud herblay
d'herblay fourniture de guerre bah oui
pour faire la guerre produits
fournitures et d'herblay on a un seul
mot oui
marc est un certain temps il commence à
mettre à 1 d apostrophes sur leur carte
de visite
messieurs je viens d'apprendre qu'ils
vous étiez des as de l'aviation
française
oui monsieur 4 à ce qu'elle en tant que
représentant du peuple
je vous adresse au nom de la patrie
toute son admiration et sa
reconnaissance
vous êtes les plus dignes représentants
de cette belle jeunesse française
indigne de vente en la patrie et robben
monsieur vous la remercierai de notre
part député je parie vous ne vous
trompez pas john holmes puis je vous
posais une question mais comment dont
vous avez des droits sur nous qu'est ce
qu'on va devenir
vous allez participer à l'oeuvre de
redressement de la france
croyez moi pour la rebâtir il va falloir
les bras et le courage de tous ses
enfants
nous ne sommes pas des maçons monsieur
nous sommes des aviateurs oui je
comprends bien voyez-vous m'enfin entend
paix les avions le sport je ne crois pas
que m
vous ne croyez pas il y à d'autres
métiers pour des jeunes gens dynamiques
oui mais nous on n'en connaît pas
d'autres et on ne veut pas en connaître
d'autres on aime ça ce que vous aimez
surtout c'est la bagarre vie sur
l'hérault la guerre donne de bien
mauvaises habitudes
entre autres celle de s'écraser en
flammes pour la patrie comme dit
monsieur au long de beurre vous savez
très bien que là où vous vous battiez
surtout pour le plaisir le plaisir
c'était votre rayon mais sur les plantes
et vous dépassez les bornes ce me semble
quelle borne celle de la bienséance ah
oui la bienséance
allez voir dans les cimetières ils sont
pleins de héros comme vous les aimez
l'efs voit bien qu'ils sont ivres
à votre santé profitez-en
les héros ont sans fatigue vite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
désolé madame d'avoir endommagé votre
cavaliers n'était pas mon cavalier
piedoux
cet hôtel appartient mon père monsieur
et vous êtes son hôte
j'ai confie notre fils à ma famille il
sera élevé au canada
je suis sûr qu'il tienne aurait été
d'accord pour défiler
avez-vous des filets avec des défis on a
filmé au moins 600 mètres de pellicule
il fallait voir la musique l'ambiance de
masse que le cinéma soit muet les
cinémas parages en attendant cher
d'albert où en êtes-vous de votre ligne
paris-marseille
mais je n'ai pas l'avion puis pourtant
il y en a des centaines qui s'entassent
sur le terrain militaire
une commission parlementaire étudie mon
cas et si vous aviez les avions qu'ils
ne sont que des appareils militaires
justine et au combat je les
transformeraient avec quoi je demanderai
une subvention
vous rendez vous compte à quel point
vous êtes seul dabert sans argent sans
appui seul alors que l'allemagne vaincue
d'hier prépare déjà sa rentrée sur le
plan international qu'elle tourne déjà
le traité de versailles en travaillant à
l'étranger pour mettre au point des
prototypes qui relègue au rang de coucou
nos vieux brillait edwards ecoute-moi
edouard cissé partait faire un reportage
sur ce que font les allemands 6 tourner
des images pas des mots des images c'est
ce que préparent les allemands tu ne
crois pas que ça réveillerait le
patriotisme de la commission ce qu'ils
ont montré ce qui se passe à l'étranger
en leur disant voilà ce qui fonde alors
et nous des images oui oui peut-être
geoffrey du voyage je me charge de tout
avec la maison
merci tous les bons mais je crois qu'il
est tard et toi vous voyez julien oui
non rien enfin areva
vous êtes sûr que ben y'en a que vous
allez tout ta question
elle vient ici c'est justement ce qu'on
aime en remercie
[Musique]
bah je me rappelais via
oh
il y en a plus de 200 entassés dans les
bois alentour
[Musique]
aviateur
on n'a pas le droit d'entrer ici c'est
un terrain militaire allons nous en tout
ça ne sert à rien
la fille était jolie moi je serais bien
resté mais les autres ont pas voulu
rangoon reparti pour le projet assurer
son service
merci est allé se coucher il y est moins
nette à l'espagne et en est mais vous
allez trouver moyen d'insulter un député
est cassé la gueule un journaliste
estime toi heureux qu'on n'ait pas cassé
la gueule aux députés c'est peut-être
lui qui préside la commission qui doit
être accordé des subventions
je me demande d'où tu tiens cette
agressivité c'est pas la guerre
alors peut-être que je tiens ça de ma
mère j'ai vu jouer bah tu le sais bien
nous avons attendu en contemplant la
photo détiennent et en disant que c'est
un [ __ ] c'est ça joséphine est partie
commence la partie
pour oum c'est reparti c'est tout bon
voyage
moi je vais me coucher via oh c'est moi
les d'herblay veulent qu'on leur donne
le baptême de l'air alors tu te souviens
de rien cette nuit les membres des
reblles et hubert et sa soeur louise way
leur père a fait mettre de zinc à notre
disposition par l'armée
je baptise le frère et la soeur marveaux
les juges quand cet après midi ils
viennent nous chercher en voiture vous
avez au projet vous m'emmener jeunes
gens n'ont pas pas à l'aviation c'est
plus de tournages
[Musique]
edwards savez vous que louise a épousé
un prince
divorcé l'année d'après conduit une
ambulance sur le pont
gagner le concours hippique de nos
villes
acculé à colonel anglais au suicide
et inventer un cocktail du port de son
nom
c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'a plus important
il y as tu prends le morane moi je
prends le sol sol
contact
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
pourquoi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
il suffit de démonter la tourelle du
mitrailleur et est utilisable
immédiatement en bricolant un peu on
arrive à loger quatre personnes y voit
perez croyez vous disent impossible de
transformer la carlingue en une cabine
fermée et étanche pour les passagers une
porte latérale ici avec une échelle
amovibles des hublots de chaque côté le
bien de vos salabert latécoère les
utilisent comme tel il a simplement fait
rajouter des boîtes en bois pour le
courrier à chacun son idée moi
j'aimerais que les voyageurs soit le
moins dépaysé possible ne peut être pas
très compatible avec la rentabilité
si nous ne pensons qu'à la rentabilité
et perez l'aviation ne sera jamais ce
que nous voudrions qu'elle soit vous
aime bien à blair
je vous promets de faire tout ce qui
sera en mon pouvoir vous faire attribuer
quelques appareils mais aussi où 16
je souffre de voir tous ces jeunes qui
seront y à ne rien faire
v
aber yachts et vient de donner à
latécoère la concession pour le courrier
aérien du maroc la ligne de barcelone va
être prolongée jusqu'à rabat cela veut
dire des pilotes en plus connaissez
latécoère
si vous lui écriviez je suis sûr qu'il
ne refuserait pas d'essayer votre ne
crois pas que julien puisse intégrer une
équipe
il est intransigeant un caractère entier
agressif
ces jeunes gens ont appris à manier le
manche en même temps que la mitrailleuse
tenez mon cocktail
il s'appelle louise
[Musique]
qu'est ce qu'il ya dedans trouverez pas
si je devine personne n'a jamais deviné
je veux connaître la récompense qui
possède mon secret le possède
si vous vous trompez je vous chasse
risque en vaut la peine
[Musique]
fine champagne cognac jeu de citron j'ai
d'orange
[Musique]
sureau d'orgeat
pointe de kirsch peut-être
encore un petit effort vous êtes presque
piment de liège vous êtes formidables
julien c'est l'impression d'être nu
devant vous
comment avez vous fait pour trouver
[Musique]
j'ai rien trouvé du tout et vous le
savez très bien je dis n'importe quoi
l'intuition alors même pas je suis sûr
que rien de tout cela ne figure dans
votre sac ça cocktail
c'est plus fort que je ne croyais bien
soit
j'ai envie de vous
[Musique]
si j'avais pas redressée on serait morts
tous les deux ensemble
on sera morts tous les deux encore jeune
sans une ride
bon c'est qu'on est beau tous les deux
parce qu'on s'aime
si julien sèmera longtemps
vous voyez ce que je veux dire il
suffirait de renforcer le fuselage par
des longerons en métal léger vous êtes
merveilleux edwards vous parlez avec
l'enthousiasmé d'un garçon de 20 ans
j'ai 20 ans c'est vrai parfois j'ai
l'impression que vous êtes plus jeune
comet fils excusez-moi continuer je vous
écoute
non ce que j'ai dit c'était pour pour me
donner une contenance je reprendrais
bien fait à boire
joséphine vous n'avez jamais songé à
vous marier
je crois que ce serait une erreur
je ne sais pas très bien où je vais mais
mais j'ai besoin d'être libre je ne veux
pas je ne veux plus dépendants d'un
homme
ma question était stupide je vous aime
beaucoup et edward parlons plutôt de
julien de plus plaisant
soyez pas mais je trouve que vous
devriez faire quelque chose pour julien
elle en a besoin mais pourquoi n'est pas
à plaindre après tout on le traite
partout en héros il couche avec la fille
d'un riche industriel
c'est moche ce que vous dites qui vous
dit que je ne fais rien pour lui
monsieur d'abord est chez lui ni le père
ni fils le fils madame huguette partir
en courant comme un fou ils avaient
l'air heureux comme s'il allait à
rendez-vous d'amour
merci
[Musique]
regarde ce que verse et monsieur nous
avons retenu votre nom comme candidat
possible pour un poste de pilote sur 12
lignes aériennes
veuillez vous présenter mercredi 17
courant à 10h au terrain de toulouse
montaudran
j'ai tenu à ce que tu sois la première à
prendre la nouvelle par caen demain
matin qu'est ce que tu fais ça pour quoi
comme c'est ma dernière soirée à paris
j'ai pensé que peut-être elle a passé
ensemble
non julien tu voudras on va jouer
bientôt la bonne chance et le plus
extraordinaire si j'aurais été demandée
pour croire que tu veux plus connu que
tu ne suppose
et puis dans le monde de l'aviation le
nombre d'abeilles poubelle sinon ce sera
pour toi par hasard après tout tu
connais latécoère être moi qui demandait
une place pour mon fils tu plaisantes
mois
[Musique]
oui mesdames et leur part rendez vous
mercredi à toulouse
petit cachottier alors non seulement tu
me poses à l'apa mais tu allais partir
sans dire au revoir
j'allais te téléphoné j'ai reçu une
convocation de latécoère à toulouse il
s'engage de nouveau pilote à toulouse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
ce thibault s'il vous plaît c'est
pourquoi je suis convoqué pour un essai
de voler je dois voir monsieur thibault
pas la peine
vous avez votre convocation suivez-moi
tu va m'attendre dans la voiture
et
vous connaissez un peu oui
desailly il en est à vous si on veut
c'est à dire il ya une soupape qui
découvrent de plus ou moins et sa mort
le ça ira ça ira
sortez leur estivaux monsieur qui vous
ne vous occupez pas de vue
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
après je sais le thibault vous attend
dans son bureau
tu l'as fait exprès ouais enfin
julien dabert je vous ai déranger pour
rien je cherche des pilotes et des
pilotes
pourtant ce comté du courrier les
passagers et rien de plus
[Musique]
voici une maquette du dernier modèle de
noël 13 banques pour le foyer
c'est le premier appareil entièrement
métallique
le revêtement est en fête et sûrs à
l'humain en tulle et ce qui lui donne
une extraordinaire revue interdite
papa
c'est toute l'europe que j'ai parcouru
ces derniers mois pour vous apporter la
preuve de la vitalité de l'aviation
allemande
les ingénieurs allemands sont partout en
suède avec henkel en suisse avec dernier
en russie avec ukr évoquèrent toutes ces
soldes tuent les arrivées tétouan voici
des images tournées à hollande où les
allemands mettent au point un avion
entièrement métallique
comment va-t-il s'est remis lentement de
ses blessures
je ne voyais presque toute sa situation
n'est pas brillante
ma charge ils te saluer la restriction
imposées à l'allemagne par de traité de
versailles
quant au nombre des pilotes n'empêche
pas de souci de tourner la difficulté à
son vol à voile qui prend la barre une
extension considérable
voilà messieurs ce que je rapporte de
mon récent voyage sur les réalisations
allemandes
oui oui vous m'entendez bien les
allemands qui ont perdu la guerre et
nous les vainqueurs où en sommes-nous en
ce mois de septembre 1920 que comptez
vous faire pour l'aviation commerciale
et où en sont les subventions que nous
attendons depuis janvier 1919 nous
n'avons pas d'argent
et si vous en voulez demandez donc à
monsieur aristide briand quand il
comptait faire payer à l'allemagne et
les 20 milliards de marks or qu'elle
doit aux alliés au titre des réparations
je pense que vous n'êtes pas d'accord
avec la politique de rapprochement avec
l'allemagne que préconise brillant pas
du tout d'accord mais laissons là la
politique et revenons aux avions si nous
n'entrons pas dès maintenant dans la
course demain il sera trop tard
ce ne sont ni les appareils ni les
pilotes ni les ingénieurs qui nous
manquent mais il nous faut agir et agir
vite
latécoère l'a très bien compris et à ses
propres risques il a lancé sa ligne
toulouse barcelone
l'exemple est mal choisi mon cher
latécoère est un aimable en rêveur qui
est en train de se ruiner pour
satisfaire ses lubies
savez vous messieurs que latécoère parle
tranquillement de relier l'europe et
d'afrique
et tenez vous bien à l'amérique du sud
l'atlantique en avion soit 3500 km alors
que les meilleurs appareils sont
incapables de franchir plus de 4 à 500
km
cela en dit long sur le sérieux du
personnage il ya vingt ans les gens
comme vous croyez qu'on ne décollerait
pas du sol enfin laissons là latécoère
et l'atlantique
je n'en demande pas tant mon intention
pour le moment est de relier paris lyon
et marseille savons le chemin de fer
pour ça monsieur et je
et trois fois moins de temps que je me
le faire pourtant ce portait combien de
passagers 3,4
la belle affaire c'est commercialement
aberrant du reste qui accepteraient de
monter à bord deux machines aussi peu
sûr quelques fous et encore vous avez
raison monsieur l'aviation est
dangereuse la preuve
avez vous d'autres arguments à nous
présenter des images que vous venez voir
ne vous suffisent donc pas où les images
les images on leur fait ce qu'on veut
des images suivent eliès a bien
reconstituée en studio le couronnement
d'edouard vii
quant à la concurrence allemande à
supposer qu elle s est manifestée nous
avons le traité de versailles
aujourd'hui vont faire injure à tous nos
morts et penser que ceux qui ont rédigé
ce traité n'ont pas fait tout le
nécessaire pour nous mettre à l'abri
d'une éventuelle renaissance de la
volonté d'hégémonie allemande le 20
juillet personne je veux des avions qui
volent et qui tisse un grand réseau
d'amitié entre les peuples
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'espère que ce coup ci ce sera le bon
ça fait huit jours que les vielles
travail en huit jours il a gagné 5 m
le toit fait vingt mètres sur 12 ici il
ya une balustrade et là une enseigne
lumineuse
ça fait comme un couloir n'offrent
coucou fumette d'envergure dommage que
l'architecte qui a conçu les galeries
lafayette n'ai pas pensé qu'un jour on
se poserait sur son tour vous êtes des
enfants les enfants qui vont se mettre
dans la poche une prime de 25 mille
francs avoue que c'est tout de même plus
rentable que faire le facteur chez
latécoère a je crois qu'il va se poser
[Musique]
c'est pas bien tous les soirs
qui sait
publie pas de poser le pied par terre
pour prenez
on les a vus
la garder l'affection pourquoi
[Musique]
je plonge davantage je le prenne moins
rasant j'ai peur de bougies et le fera
nanard tu pourrais pas de consolider un
peu nombreux mais sa malle l'alourdir
les galeries lafayette pourquoi pas la
torah scène des zombies pas pour qu'on
réussisse pour l'affront je vais
emprunter beaucoup d'argent au malawi
pillay
la tirer à pile ou face c'est lui qui a
gagné gagné ou perdu
et toi tu veux nous porter la poisse ce
reportage que tu fais c'est pour passer
entre salles de cinéma ah oui bien sûr
mais il n'y aura pas de vous il y aura
aussi vos concurrents et où on sentit
our guère plus avancé que vous une idée
de la date à laquelle il compte tenter
l'atterrissage merci parle de trois
semaines védrine d'un mois pour qu'on
réussisse avant
me plaît beaucoup olivier pourquoi tu
dis ça
[Musique]
si vous n'avez plus besoin de moi je
parlais rejoint de monsieur edouard oui
l'armée a fini par mettre à sa
disposition un breguet pour sa ligne
toujours aussi rêveur peut-être un rêve
plus utile que de se poser sur les
galeries lafayette
à bientôt olivier vous pouvez m'appeler
julie boulet joséphine j'aime bien moi
comme prénom
[Rires]
alors le voilà ce premier appareil des
messageries du civ allons pas trop vite
joséphine
il faut d'abord voir ce qu'il a dans le
ventre ternon il est pas frais je
comprends pas qu'on vous ait refilé un
pari coucou et dire qu'il ya des
centaines d'avions ont été construits
juste avant l'armistice et qui n'ont
jamais volé je sais je n'ai pas que des
amis
on essaye le moulin fernand si vous y
tenez monsieur édouard
quant à day et l'algérie
[Musique]
oh
je n'ai pas tous les deux vous faites
les mécanos le nôtre avec edward c'est
la misère pour petits pilotes
heureusement que louise est là ça y est
c'est la région un beau petit papier
signé papa d'herblay qui vaut 15 mille
francs c'est cher pour un jouet il a
accepté comme ça il n'a pas demandé de
garanties
quelles garanties c'est mon cadeau de
noël avec un peu d'avancé
alors je te plies comme commanditaire
tu me jure que c'est olivier qui
pilotera et wii n'attire à pile ou face
et après qu'est ce que tu comptes faire
après on verra pour l'instant il faut
qu'on gagne
[Musique]
j'ai toujours aussi sûr de gagner
et
au lendemain de la grande guerre
les as de la chasse française se sont
retrouvés sans occupation
certains ont abandonné l'aviation
d'autres traînent leur mélancolie de
meeting en meeting
un des pionniers de l'aviation edward
adhère continuer à se battre pour créer
une ligne à l'image de latécoère qui
déjà exploite paris-barcelone lisant
l'afrique et plus tard l'amérique du sud
joséphine leroux jeune canadienne veuve
d'un pilote a battu au combat est devenu
journaliste pour une compagnie
d'actualités cinématographiques
julien lambert le fils d'édouard pilote
de chasse est allé se présenter à
toulouse chez latécoère pour obtenir un
poste de pilote de ligne
[Musique]
après une démonstration brillante trois
brillantes julien dabert est refusé par
thibault le patron
on cherche des pilotes par des acrobates
julien rendre à paris où il retrouve
louise sa maîtresse fille d'un riche
industriel
je lien avec son ami jules olivier tente
de mettre au point d'atterrissage sur le
toit des galeries lafayette un exploit
doté de 25 ils font le prix
[Musique]
pendant ce temps edward vader s'acharne
à vouloir créer sa ligne aérienne
[Musique]
moi je suis pas d'accord je m'en fous
classement encore suis un bon c'est fait
ben non mais ça va ça fera pour quatre
passagers plus le courrier
tu comprends pas tête de mule que si je
l'essaie à vide ça veut rien dire
et si vous l'essayez en pleine charge et
vous vous cassez la gueule on verra bien
c'est pas brad risquer la vie des
passagers
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je croyais que c'était vous qui devait
piloter julien et moi on a eu des mots
il croit pouvoir faire mieux que moi je
lui donnais le manche pour qu'ils se
rendent compte savez qu'il est
orgueilleux capable de tout pour réussir
je sais faut savoir prendre ses risques
[Applaudissements]
olivier oui vous n'avez jamais pensé à
la mort
pourquoi voulez vous que je pense à
quelque chose qui n'existe pas
[Musique]
vous n'avez pourtant vu durant la guerre
j'ai vu la mort des autres pas la mienne
dangereux ça
olivier
voulez-vous me prendre à piloter
alors
pourquoi pas
à quand la première leçon tout de suite
d'accord
oui il va venir chercher julien
on restera celle de tous les deux
[Applaudissements]
il aurait tellement voulu me donner une
leçon
heureusement que louise est pas encore
arrivé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'aurais voulu janeiro décembre a pas de
romantisme hr la théorie c'est tout
[Applaudissements]
j'aurais voulu aller loin
plus loin il ya je ne sais plus quel
philosophe aviateurs qui a dit oui au
moins 20 ans de ville en ville de crête
en crête de continent en continent
j'espère que ce n'est pas ce que vous
ressentez mon dieu ce n'est pas ce que
vous souhaitez non moi ce serait plutôt
l'alcool en alcool
on essaye guillaume apollinaire il a
écrit un recueil de vers qui s'appelle
alcool ou débuts à la chanson du mal à
mener un soir de demi brume à londres un
voyou qui ressemblait à mon amour 21
rencontres
le regard qu'il me jeta mfi baisser les
yeux honte quelle connerie qui il y en a
plein air non non il est mort le 9
novembre 18 et dans la rue la foule
criait à bas guillaume
[Musique]
quand est-ce que tu seras à moi quand je
serais quelque chose pour toi
[Musique]
je serai à autre chose qu'une victoire
tu en as descendu combien 27 homologués
[Musique]
à temps à peu au début oui à temps
mais pas trop
j'aime pas attendre bien des choses vite
fuir
je suis pressé tu comprends il ya le
fort serrières moi qui le pousse
suis je suis comme tous les fils de la
chance
l'impression que si je rate quelque
chose fait rater tout le reste
[Musique]
[Rires]
j'accepte l'effet yoyo ont fait rien
ce qui m'a pris
tu m'as tellement peur
je suis envahie par les deux avions
d'abord c'est là il est un mois un mois
+ entend bien géré proche d'al plus ça
dépend que nous avons vallerey plus à ma
chère c'est une phrase de trop julien je
recommence
[Musique]
il avait donc costa dans la peau oui
je crois qu'il faudra t'y faire si l'on
pense parfaite
bah ouais tu vous espionne
ok on est à peu près au même bureau
je crois que c'est védrine qui va
empocher les 25000 francs
que le meilleur gagne
oui oui et plus de femmes pour reprise
et les chaussettes et élever la
marmaille il c'est vrai il n'y aura
bientôt plus de femmes pourquoi deux
femmes vous connaissez la nouvelle quoi
adrienne bolland à traverser la
cordillère des andes abordage et 3 le
même appareil que le nôtre la cordillère
des andes
ouais il muraille de 4500 mètres à
l'aide d'un coucou qui plafonne à 3000
la russie le 1er avril quand le consul
de france a appris la nouvelle il a cru
que c'était un poisson d'avril
[Applaudissements]
à
[Rires]
[Musique]
j'abandonne un regarde le ciel je me dis
que c'est facile oui mais pour finir est
trop de gens pater qui me retiennent qui
comprend non tu peux trouver quelque
chose d'autre que moi monsieur edouard
jacque à toulouse chez l'as tu es avec
la la mer pour des jeunes comme vous qui
est de la race des pionniers cette
reconversion doit être dur je ne veux
pas que vous la considériez comme un
pis-aller
je ne suis pas homme à me compromettre
perez si je suis là ce que je pense
pouvoir servir encore les idées qui me
sont chers c'était pratiquement sur le
sable vous m'avez appelé qu'attendez
vous de moi
la france orient est une société dont
les capitaux viennent d'un peu partout
mais essentiellement de france nous
voulons explorer les possibilités de
l'aviation commerciale dans cet axe
aujourd'hui plus tard mon vieux rêve que
vous voulez comme vous pouvez vous en
rendre compte
la plaque tournante de la compagnie et
l'escale de munich munich
c'est à la fois bucarest d'une part et
d'autre part dites-moi munich
c'est en allemagne non justement
nous avons pensé qu'un homme comme vous
qui avez eu des contacts importants avec
les allemands avant la guerre et même
pendant je crois oui en effet j'ai été
prisonnier mais je me suis évadé nous
avons pensé que vous étiez l'homme de la
situation pour obtenir des allemands
grâce à vos contacts humains toutes les
facilités nécessaires à l'ouverture de
l'escale de munich
[Musique]
je viens julien tu viens à tempérer
devenir représentant de commerce
[Musique]
oui je vais habiter ici c'est d'accord
bonsoir
julien et moi on a décidé de vivre
ensemble il m'a proposé ici chez moi
c'était difficile vous n'y voyez pas
d'inconvénient
moi je n'en vois pas et peut-être que
vous vous en verrez je vous êtes
habitués au luxe aux domestiques n'y a
pas d'autres familles si le matin c'est
moi qui fais le café
quant à vous le portez jolie maman de
temps d'ailleurs c'était une proposition
en l'air dès demain je pars pour munich
pour quoi faire monnayer mes amitiés
bien bien moi avez quoi contre téhéran
n'est ce pas parler ses entretiens dans
cette jeune femme je t'en prie
écoute moi bien génial je n'ai presque
plus d'argent si j'ai réussi cette
mission qu'on me confier je n'aurai plus
qu'un salaire d'employés et oui j'ai
bien fini le temps des aventures il y
aura toujours des aventures et des
hommes pour les vivre tue ce qui
t'arrive tu vieillis tu devrais te
remarier paris et plein de jeune et
jolie veuve de guerre qui ne demande qu
à convoler avec de brebières comme toi
tu n'es pas seulement bêtes tuées
grossier
[Applaudissements]
quand faire traiter de maquereaux
et maintenant tu me reconnais edourad
abers oui j'ai tellement changé en
quatre ans toi tu es toujours le même
j'ai eu du mal à trouver tu sais je suis
allée deci delà
maintenant je suis installé à munich
constructeur d'air pour la voyais son de
bronze oiseaux oui sans moteur nous
étions des mauvais élèves ou nous avait
privés de dessert je te gêne je peux
repartir
j'ai été tellement surpris
et puis tous ces temps ci on ne parle
pas beaucoup france et en allemagne
c'est comme chez nous
je t'embrasse
ces semaines pour moi c'est un public
que tu as fait le voyage
non non j'ai besoin de toi
sophie relation tout ce que je pourrai
faire pire que j'aie déposants
[Applaudissements]
edward abbey foster et puis de zilina
dis moi qui est cette jeune femme le
titre avait qu'à demander
déjà 400 heures de vol à moteur et en
hollande
elle a perdu son mari en 1918 il faut
bien que les blessures
ses cicatrices le faut oui à tout prix
même si les blessures que nous nous
sommes fait son profondeur quelqu'un je
connais en france car edward toujours
ses docteurs mais parce que tu crois non
il s'agit de joséphine leroux et la
femme détiennent leur ont descendu en
flammes
c'était la games
les blessures sont cicatrisées bien sûr
allez dire
maintenant l'heure est elle tournait
autour du pot
est ce que tu es venu fait à munich
je suis venu demander mon ami hans
ministère de me faire profiter des
relations qu'il a dans l'aviation et les
milieux politiques allemands eu égard à
son renom pour implanter à munich une
escale de la compagnie france orient de
navigation aérienne que j'ai l'honneur
de représenter
eh bien tu avais marre et être franc la
franchise a toujours présidé à nos
rapports non et war est ce que vous vous
rendez compte que vous êtes en allemagne
au mois de mai 1921 que vous français
occupent et francfort est en stade et
que vos troupes cambrin silésie que vous
nous demandez pas milliards de marks or
avant la fin du mois au titre des
réparations
alors que la majorité du peuple allemand
estime qu'elle n'a pas la responsabilité
du déclenchement de la guerre le moment
parfaitement compte pour ce qui est de
ces 20 milliards n'en fait pas tout un
plat
vous nous en avait bien demandé cinq ans
70 quant à la suite de la guerre je
pense que votre président monsieur riber
est le nôtre monsieur aristide briand
ferons tout ce qu'il faut pour calmer
les esprits l'heure est à la
réconciliation
la politique est une chose les hommes tu
veux emprunter une compagnie phase est
au coeur de l'allemagne une concurrente
directe alors que nous sommes dans le
pétrin
tu connais la situation en allemagne
qui sait combien nous avons des chômeurs
évidemment chez nous c'est autre chose
il nous faut reconstruire notre pays la
guerre ait lieu sur notre territoire et
mouthe
à combien il est d'autres chemins
aujourd'hui cela doit être 25 pour 1
dollar je crois hier c'était 20 en 1914
il fallait quatre maputo la demande ce
sera 50 cent voilà pour la situation
antérieure
edward tu vas devant de grandes
difficultés
personne ici ne s'accordera une aide tu
représentes les traiter les visas et
c'est pour nous une iniquité
à moins que tu es quelque chose à nous
offrir
je n'ai rien à vous offrir
je viens tout demander pour l'aviation
mais c'est d'abord je vous trouve
merveilleux permettez que je vous
embrasse
il ne faut pas nous laisser ses paris il
ya trop de morts entre nous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ramses 2 heures 10 3 euros en fait de
belles choses ce propos et la wii comme
elton rester en allemagne mais le temps
qu'il fera
bon je vais voir ce que je peux faire
malgré les énormes difficultés que nous
connaissons notre aviation commerciale
se développent en ce qui concerne munich
nous avons déjà un terrain équipé qui
est le terminal provisoire de la droite
celle où retrait devrait vous allez
employés au sol du personnel allemand
j'espère monsieur d'affaires mais avant
que nous abordions les questions de gros
sous monsieur hirschberg je voudrais
vous dire ceci
l'aviation a été et sera toujours
l'unique patients de ma vie je vais
m'employer à donner aux plus d'hommes
possible du moyen de voyager d'aller
voir les voisins immédiats ou lointains
pour qu'ils apprennent à les connaître
car voyez-vous monsieur aschberg quand
les gens se connaissent ils arrivent
plus difficile de s'entretuer nous
accepterons de mettre nos moyens à votre
disposition
mais à deux conditions premièrement vous
utiliserez au sol du personnel allemand
deuxièmement il sera stipulé dans le
contrat que la compagnie française
s'engage lorsque ce sera devenu possible
à user de réciprocité et mettre à notre
disposition son infrastructure en france
enfin et ceci est un sou est un sou est
très vif que notre ami hans ma star aura
sa place auprès de vous nous
n'envisageons pas le pilotage de vos
appareils
puisque le traité de versailles interdit
à nos pilotes de survoler votre
territoire
[Musique]
si la relance laissez moi dormir c'est
de voir l'équipe se soit jeté du café
vous voulez nous avons tout essayé
elle colle pas il vient fait casser du
bois au moins dix fois dont quatre ont
encore faudrait apporter des
modifications énormes vous changer
d'appareil alors olivier va tenter sa
chance comme ça ne vous êtes des
insensés et s'il rate son coup ce qui
est probable qu'il s'écrase dans la rue
sur toute une bande d'imbéciles qui
seront là le nez en l'air
l'e10 dont c'étaient des imbéciles ce
qu'avaient les en l'air pour te regarder
voler toi ya 20 ans ce n'était pas la
même chose évidemment avec vingt ans
d'écart ce n'est jamais la même chose
nous n'avons jamais voulu faire de
cirque le cirque c'est un autre métier
avec tout vos folies vous rendez les
gens méfiants ne croiront jamais à
l'aviation
chaque fois que nous voudrons faire
voyager les gens en avion ils croiront
que le pilote doit faire des acrobaties
et ils continueront à prendre le chemin
de fer parce que le chemin de fer lui il
ne fait pas de looping c'est tout bon
écoute moi bien je te propose de changer
de vie la france orient aura besoin de
pilotes
il est bon je suis prête à m'engager et
je crois - si tu aimes les exploits qui
seront servis partir et arriver à
l'heure par n'importe quel temps sept
jours par semaine
c'est la mère j'ai entendu la fin de
votre conversation je ne crois pas qu'il
fasse la faire je serai votre belle
assurance petite madame puisque nous
parlons à faire tu viens n'a pas fini de
vous rencontrer vous avez fait si vite
je suis presque pris au dépourvu les
circonstances m'ont aidé vous savez il
ya beaucoup à faire avant de lancer le
premier vol régulier paris munich dit -
perez
vous voyez tous nos appareils et de
l'adsl pour effet en communication
constante avec le sol les pilotes en
contact permanent avec leurs bases
d'abord nous faisons ou un visionnaire
pour le bien de l'accompagner je presse
après que tout ceci est un visionnaire
savez vous combien pèse un émetteur
récepteur
savez vous quelle est la portée de ces
appareils
et savez-vous qu'il a été matériellement
trouvé qu'il n'était pas possible à une
machine plus leur colère de décoller
[Applaudissements]
s'est posé sur le toit des galeries
lafayette de mise au point
[Musique]
moi non monfils oui
[Applaudissements]
on a gagné c'est réussi védrine arrive
si il s'est posé sur le toit des
galeries lafayette je viens d'entendre
la tsf deux mois
-la prime
des primes y en ad'autres gagner
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
[Rires]
tu m'as fait peur cet après midi rien
par rapport à ce qui nous attend
je ne sais pas s'ils se tiendrait le
coup tu tiendras parce que tu m'aimes
parce qu'il faut que je te rembourse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
m
[Musique]
[Rires]
c'est donc mieux que football non c'est
bien cru que tu allais me rentrer dedans
non voyants nsa un ami ou danser louise
[Musique]
et la maîtresse d'olivier as encore
comment ça pas encore une pose une
question je te réponds
pas encore ça viendra c'est pourquoi
lorsque j'en ai envie parce que je suis
une famille libre de disposer de ma vie
comme tu es libre de disposer la tienne
évidemment il plaît beaucoup aux femmes
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
elles ont une sorte d'instinct les
femmes quand un homme va mourir elle le
sentent alors à lui offre ce qu'elles
sont moi c'est mon corps qui est
complètement folle
olivier c'est que c'est la fin d'une
époque bientôt il n'y aura plus de place
pour nous je n'ai jamais remarqué que
c'était toujours lui qui prenait des
risques
il te protège julien je ne sais pas
comment il s'éprend
[Musique]
vous ajouterez un verre pour moi et
aujourd'hui c'est moi qui paye bonsoir
belle journaliste ne bois pas trop
demain tu fais ton premier vol en solo
pour soir louise soir julien elle nous
boude savez ce qu'ils ont trouvé
l'ictu olivier ya vingt-cinq mille
francs de primes aux premiers équipages
qui changera toutes les bougies d'un
moteur en vol
quelle folie n'ai pas essayé je viens
pilotera et moi je ferai mes cadeaux on
a déjà commencé à s'entraîner
[Musique]
réussiront jamais construit cet olivier
qui risque le plus
[Rires]
with garder les horaires n est pas une
autruche
vous les allées du personnel au sol
c'est un problème intérieur mais pour
l'essence et a dit phil tank est
aujourd'hui ça fait 70 morts comme toi
là c'est de la folie
bon eh bien nous ferons venir l'essence
de france par train puis par camion
[Musique]
est ce que c'est un gros cochon aura du
coton ne la concerne pas des mimosas par
une petite grille qu'il a ramassé avec
marthe beaucoup trop de bruit est
partout 65 me suffit t'as pas un peu
d'argent
[Musique]
quoique
je vois il aurait normalement ça va bien
sûr me suis dit
[Musique]
les trois hommes solides à 1000 $ pour
un bouquet de mimosas
mais les mimosas à cette époque de
l'année c'est dans le midi que
[Musique]
voulez-vous les camps celui mozac
olivier et moi seul cet après midi à
saint que ça vous lasse 12 brigade au
parler ici à 5 heures l'après midi vous
verser les 20 mille dollars à georges
j'ai confiance en lui
[Musique]
nous faisons key était dire est que leur
monnaie chinoise un programme a demandé
[Musique]
avant de recommander un pote ces braves
et les contraindre à la volée what a
waster n'est pas d'accord pourquoi ce
sera toi parce que je suis le meilleur
c'est à voir
[Musique]
vous
il efface d'accord parce j'y vais pile
c'est toi
[Musique]
en retour nous
m
[Musique]
oh
ici
cinq heures l'après midi
tiens je la donne le peuple est leur
servir
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
ah ah
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
un peu
oh